يبدو أنه فوتوغرافي من كل زاوية ،
هناك ثوران مذهل لـ Beauty tivanaloa
خاصة كما تم التقاطه بواسطة
المصور CJ Kale
Volcano مختلفًا كل يوم في
كل مرة تذهب فيها ، دائمًا ما يكون
CJ مختلفًا يقودنا إلى
مكانه المثالي للصور في الرابعة
صباحًا أفضل منظر  إنه يعتقد أن
الشمس المشرقة تحيي الحمم المتوهجة
لساعات طويلة من النوم ضحى
بها لبضع دقائق فقط من إضاءة
الطقس المثالية مما يسمح لنا بالخروج إلى
المطر البارد على أمل أن يحترق بينما
ننتظر CJ يعترف لنا أنه نوع معين
من  طالب الإثارة مدمن الحمم ، أنت
تعرف نوع المصطلح الموجود
هنا كلنا نطلق على أنفسنا مدمن الحمم ،
إنه نوع من الإصلاح الذي نخرجه
وهو ما يمنحنا الإثارة وهو
ما يمنحنا الأدرينالين لليوم الذي
يمتلكه مدمن الحمم هذا  حتى إذا ذهبت
للسباحة وهي تلتقط هذه الموجات النارية في
ثوران كيلويا لعام 2018 ، صباح الخير ، حسنًا ،
نعم ، إذا التقطت
تقريرنا المباشر يوم الاثنين لشبكة CNN هذا الصباح ،
فأنت ميج  لقد لاحظ فريق التحرير أن مصباحًا أماميًا لهذا الشخص
عند عودته من رحلة إلى
حافة الحمم البركانية ، وقد حذر المسؤولون مرارًا
وتكرارًا الناس من مخاطر
الاقتراب من التدفق ناهيك عن
التعدي على ممتلكات كورتيس وشيري يتذمر
ربما قام مدمنو الحمم الصاعدون بالسير
لمدة خمس ساعات ذهابًا وإيابًا فوق الحمم غير المستقرة
صخرة إلى حافة التدفق ، قاموا
بتسجيل هذا الفيديو على بعد حوالي 50 ياردة
من الحمم الزاحفة ،
ثم كان هناك أولئك الذين يذهبون إلى
مصدر الحمم البركانية خبراء الحمم
البركانية إذا كنت ستعمل على جمع عينات من الحمم البركانية من هيئة المسح الجيولوجي الأمريكية (USGS) وإحضارها.
هنا وهكذا وضعناهم في
أفران التجفيف ، تساعد جامعة هاواي في هيلو في
تشغيل معمل الاستجابة السريعة
لثوران ماونا لوا ، حصلنا على نظرة نادرة
داخل هذه العينات التي تم جمعها
منذ أن بدأت الحمم البركانية
تقذفها في الهواء و  هبطت
وهل قاموا بجمعها أه بينما
كانت لا تزال منصهرة وأطفأتها
وإذا نظرت إليها سترى أنها
ناعمة جدًا يمكنك الإعجاب بها  يكسرها بين
يديك باحثو الكربون والأكسجين
هنا بسرعة يخرجون البيانات لمساعدة
مخطط هيئة المسح الجيولوجي الأمريكية (USGS) حيث قد يتجه تدفق الحمم البركانية
إلى أي نقطة تحولت إلى
تدمير عندما وضعنا منزلاً بالطريقة
التي لا يمكنك القيام بها لذلك أنا  فقدت ممتلكات
خلال ثوران عام 2018 ، لدي العديد من
الأصدقاء الذين فقدوا ممتلكات أمي فقدت
منزلًا لزوجين لا
نعتبره خسارة ، فنحن نعتبره وقتًا مستعارًا
نتحدث عن وقت Sun's Up وما
زلنا نرى هذا
يشعر وكأنه  الانجراف
عندما تصل إلى هذه النقطة وفجأة
لا يوجد شيء
تشعر بخيبة الأمل ، تعلم أنه
جزء من الرحلة إذا كانت كل مرة
نتوقف فيها عن العمل
مدهشة للغاية ، فلن تكون خاصة كما
هي عليه  الأيام التي كان فيها رائعًا